White House chief strategist Steve been
and joined Donald Trump's presidential
campaign in August 2016 but the former
executive chairman of the right-wing
website Breitbart news has been part of
Donald Trump's trusted circle for many
years the new book devil's bargain
Steve Bannon Donald Trump when the
storming of the presidency chronicles
the inner twine pass of both men and how
they reached the White House author
Joshua Greene writes any study of
Trump's rise to the presidency is
therefore unavoidably a study of Bannon
to Greene is the senior national
correspondent for Bloomberg Businessweek
we welcome him here to the day thank you
thank you to have you you you've known
Bannon since 2011
talked to him on and off the record
sense I wonder I want to start with this
I mean that their relationship was
strained when he started Steve Bannon is
back in the president's good graces now
that's right so I met Benton in 2011
long before he knew about Trump or
anybody was thinking about the events
that it kind of maker to you he was a
filmmaker he was this kind of Fringe
character in Washington that not a lot
of people knew about our ever thought
would be important so the book
essentially tells the story the inside
story of how Trump and Bannon came
together the rise of the all right and
bannon's years long plot to tear down
Hillary Clinton which was really I think
what endeared him to Trump what God
helped get Trump elected of course then
they had a kind of a falling out when
when bannon's profile rose to a level
that Trump wasn't comfortable cover of
Time magazine cover of Time magazine
called him the great manipulator you
know he had this kind of dramatic fall
and now he's back but what did he do
Donald I think he did two things for
Donald Trump that I covered in the book
one is Bannon was the mastermind of an
interlocking group of political
organizations funded by a right-wing
billionaire whose mission was to tear
down Hillary Clinton the goal wasn't to
do that for Trump this was long before
Trump was the nominee but it was clear
that Clinton was probably going to be
the Democratic candidate and Trump wound
up being the beneficiary of bandhans
efforts the other thing he did is when
he took over Trump's campaign in August
Trump was really floundering in the
polls Bannon managed to get Trump
focused away from megyn kelly away
from the Khan family and use all that
anti-hillary knowledge to keep him
focused on the opposite but he'd already
begun to talk about issues that Bannon
liked in terms of immigration and and a
kind of populism too he had him if you
look at Trump and I do it a chapter on
Trump's political history before been
and he has always had these populist
impulses back in the 80s you could hear
him talking about trade deals and
instead of maligning China
he was maligning Japan so there was a
lot of overlap political overlap between
Trump and ban and to begin with but I
think Bannon really brought the idea of
illegal immigration and understood its
power as a political issue and Trump
really became the vessel for those ideas
and it's what carried him to the white
but Bannon also called him the imperfect
vessel right yes so they don't they're
not together on everything they're not
together on everything I think Bannon
like most of us certainly myself did not
understand from the get-go what a
powerful politician Donald Trump was
going to be Bandon was in advising him
informally as long ago as 2010 thought
he was an interesting guy but nobody
thought that he would win the nomination
or the presidency only when he knocked
out the rest of the Republican field I
think they can powerful politician apart
from banner not anybody else
I think that he has this great personal
force as a candidate I mean we saw in
the Republican primaries Donald Trump
doesn't think a lot about policy but
he's able to kind of dominate his
opponents in a way that most politicians
aren't and and he used a lot of Van
Daan's ideas to do that and to knock out
what everybody thought was the strongest
Republican presidential field in a
generation
I remember watching on Inauguration Day
it was a rainy day if you recall and
once everybody already left including
the president everyone went back into
the Capitol two people stayed at the
podium
Steve Bannon Kellyanne Conway sort of
looking out of the terrace and saying
you know look at what we've accomplished
and
bannon's mind could donald trump have
won the presidency without his aid I
think if you tortured Bannon he wouldn't
answer that question but my answer to
that question is no I don't think Trump
could have for two reasons one that
abandons efforts especially the book
Clinton cash which we
remember from the outset of the campaign
which bandit helped mastermind really
tarnished his opponent in a way that she
never fully recovered from and then on
the flip side his ability to keep Trump
focused on Clinton in the homestretch of
the race and then he had the James Comey
revelations and and suddenly Trump was
able to pull ahead I give Bandhan a lot
of credit for having helped Trump do
that is it possible now that there's
going to be some kind of up split
between Trump base which is which Bannen
also has served well because of the
kinds of things that are happening in
terms of the welfare of that group of
populist Americans you know it's
interesting there haven't been any signs
or they've been very few signs that
Trump is losing his base it's that's
that that's happened he's lost he never
had the support of Democrats he's lost a
lot of the support that he had with
independence but his base has stuck with
him the kind of people that Steve been
in talks to have so far stuck with him
the question is going to be can Trump
ever deliver anything for these people
legislatively or is he gonna spend four
years in mesh and scandal the same time
during the election he also got
independence he got Rust Belt Democrats
I mean there it was a broader audience
than just his base well I count them as
being part of his base but but
ultimately he needs to deliver for them
economically and fulfill some of these
promises he made and there's no sign yet
that he's really gonna be able to do
that in any area other than cracking
down on illegal immigration which of
course was one of trumps big promises we
have to mention we did reach out to the
White House for comments on the
reporting in your book we have not heard
back about what what they think about
all that but Steve banner I mean this is
a guy also who made a lot of money and
has now made a lot of political hay
railing against the élysée and the folks
who have a lot of money I mean I suppose
not dissimilar to Donald Trump in that
way
how does he Square his his his worldview
and sort of how he's developed here
financially you know III think it's
similar in a way to Donald Trump me he
was a guy who was very smart who
succeeded in all sorts of different
realms but came from a blue-collar Navy
family deeply traditional
catholic background managed to get into
Harvard Business School kind of survived
by his own wits and Goldman Sachs and in
Hollywood I think that really gave him a
connection to Trump who saw him as a
deal maker as someone who spoke his
language as somebody who's comfortable
with moguls and as somebody who had
ideas that Trump recognized I think even
just in an intuitive level could advance
Trump's political career they play down
at any tension between him and Jarrett
Kushner's well fascinating book I know
you've wanted to interview him since you
first met him thank you so much thank
you thank you